if you're tired of your bank ripping you
off click the link below to learn about
our sponsor current which is an awesome
alternative to dealing with big banks
I'll tell you more about them at the end
of the video here's a question that
seems pretty basic and pretty simple but
it's really not quite so straightforward
how does an economic recession or
depression end in other words we know
that they happen and we know that
eventually they end but what is the
mechanism exactly we might be in a
recession right now we could be heading
into a depression right now this could
extend for months or years some are
saying to some degree we are going to
have very high unemployment for several
years at some point what we are in will
end unless this is the end of planet
Earth how does it all end we know that
we have a lot of self-fulfilling
prophecies that can get us into a
recession but can those same
self-fulfilling prophecies get us out
now this is not we know when do we when
we say that something has ended this is
not about the statistic that tells us we
are out of the recession or the
depression we can argue about that and
some people would say well it's based on
GDP GDP tells you when you're out of a
recession what I'm talking about is not
how can we tell when we are out I'm
talking about what is the mechanism that
gets an economy out of a recession or a
depression is it that we see more hiring
and unemployment goes down is it that
the stock market goes up and makes
people confident is it just people's
confidence in and of itself which is a
cause versus an effect these are not
simple economic questions and what you
really need are two major things to get
out of an economic downturn first the
cause of the downturn needs to be
clearly resolved and then number two you
need a combination of economic policy
and business conditions to start an
actual recovery in terms of the numbers
but you also need consumer sentiment to
change this is a reality in economies
like ours that are heavily driven by the
perception of their own State
and that is that people fearing a
recession starting to spend less can
precipitate one but also people feeling
as though the situation has been
resolved and starting to spend more and
demand more in and of itself can help to
get us out of a recession so yeah people
feeling like the recession is over is a
big part of the recession being over and
it can seem recursive or endlessly
regressive this is arguably not good
about our economic system I think it's
important to understand that so much of
how we are doing as an economy is about
how people believe that we are doing but
for now this is our system and consumer
sentiment is part of getting out of a
depression because when people believe
we are out or soon to be out they start
acting as though we are out which gets
us out because people start spending and
demanding goods and services so let's
think back to 2008 ok the Great
Recession of 2008 two things happened to
stop that recession and to get us out of
it number one the underlying issue which
was the fear of huge financial
institutions being insolvent as a result
of the mortgage crisis and some other
reasons that was resolved sort of in the
sense that we had some new regulations
we had the belief that we've put in
place new lending guidelines so the
mortgage crisis can't happen again we've
cleaned up some corruption supposedly
even though nobody went to jail but the
point is there was the belief that the
underlying cause had been resolved that
was a big part of it in addition though
we had a lot of economic policy response
under the Obama administration that got
us out that included that huge stimulus
package that Republicans were furious
about that Barack Obama did it included
new government spending it included some
tax cuts so that was 2008 the difference
now with the current recession or what
some are saying is an inevitable
depression that's coming related to
coronavirus is that it is not a
financial institution recession in
principle what we have here is a corona
virus pandemic
which decimated demand for stuff because
of the pandemic because of the virus
demand for travel went down 90 95
percent in some cases demand for office
space collapsed demand for restaurants
collapsed all of that stuff so the
resolution to this one is not about
government spending money or sending
people cash government needs to do that
as a stopgap so that people don't starve
or lose their homes or lose their cars
or lose their businesses that they hope
to go back to but the underlying issue
here to be solved is a medical issue we
need treatment we need a vaccine so for
now government's role is a little bit
different in this recession than it was
in 2008 government needs to provide
support for people to keep them and
businesses afloat in a sort of waiting
period it's a bridge in a sense once the
underlying issue the virus is resolved
demand in principle should start to
recover now it's only going to recover
in proportion to people's ability to
demand things now when we say demand
we're talking about it economically I
can demand a private jet in the sense
that it sounds cool but when I talk
about economic demand it means that
there is actually the money with which
to demand these things in an economic
system so as people feel safe going to
restaurants they will go to restaurants
and the restaurants will make money
they'll pay employees they'll buy stuff
from food supply companies the employees
will go out and spend money at other
local businesses the food supply
companies seeing more demand from
restaurants will start ordering more
food from producers and the economic
activity will resume traveling will you
know then increase but increased air
travel will mean that people are going
to be places they don't live which means
they will demand hotel stays and on and
on and on now a reasonable question
would be and one that we should be
asking is there a way to prevent these
recessions in the first place now
preventing them altogether is tough and
there's a difference between a medically
based recession like coronavirus and
something like we saw in 2008 the
financial crisis
no doubt that we could organize
economies in a way that would soften
these recessions and make them less
severe there are some realities about
our economic system um there are booms
and busts that's how capitalism works
and we have a capitalism in the United
States that is not nearly regulated
enough there is no incentive in systems
like ours to be proactive proactive
means you're spending money you might
not need to spend and you're reducing
your profits in the immediate that we
being proactive is not incentivized by
the system that we have we are reactive
so when the boom turns to a bust it's
really big and a ton of people suffer
greatly in the last three months we
learned about this many systems that
feel strong low unemployment high stock
market high consumer confidence looked
like a very strong infrastructure it was
really quite fragile in about a two-week
period it imploded if all along we had a
more solid infrastructure we would
suffer not nearly as much during these
downturns so for example if everybody
had healthcare not connected to their
employer losing a job during a pandemic
would be less of a crisis it would still
be a crisis but it would be less of a
crisis if health insurance was not tied
to employment another example if we had
universal basic income or something like
it
jobs guarantee whatever flavor you like
the loss of jobs or reductions in wages
would be less problematic
it wouldn't be irrelevant but it would
be less urgently problematic and the
government would not be in as much of a
position of acutely having to figure out
we got to start sending out checks
direct deposits debit prepaid debit
cards all this different stuff it would
be less of a crisis so the the lesson
that hopefully we would learn here is we
can't prevent a future pandemic from a
novel virus could happen again it likely
will happen again we can't prevent any
up-and-down in the economy even if we
ensure you know putting it in different
insurance policies there are business
cycles and there are going to be ups and
down
but what Social Democrats like me want
is more investment from the fruits of
when things are going well to put in
place social insurance policies that
will raise the standard of living for
everybody get more people off of that
borderline paycheck-to-paycheck
situation where if you don't work for
two weeks
you now are unable to meet your basic
expenses let's make the system less
fragile for when things like this happen
in the future
it's no secret on the show that I am
very critical of the big banks and how
they screw over customers in so many
ways and if you're like me you're
probably sick of the fees and the
hassles that come with a checking
account at a big traditional bank by now
in that case check out the online bank
current they're one of our sponsors if
you're watching on YouTube this here is
my actual debit card for my current
checking account which I'm holding up
with current you've got no minimum
balance no overdraft fees up to $100 no
ATM fees you can use over fifty five
thousand ATMs nationwide unlike with
other banks you receive your direct
deposit instantly meaning you'll get
paid by your employer up to two days
sooner you can deposit checks instantly
using your camera phone 24/7 member
support and unlike with other banks
current instantly refunds that hold on
your card when you pump gas you can
pause your debit card instantly which is
really useful there are just so many
different advantages to ditching the big
banks and instead use a bank that puts
their members first it takes two minutes
to sign up they'll immediately ship you
your debit card for free go ahead and
get started by clicking the link down
below the video